yeah welcome to this game playing on
freedom master here from from Turkey
let's check if I if I know this guy el
power fa other one no don't know him ok
so an Enzo and let's see what line you
always need to be a bit cautious with
with the Turkish players the thing is
they have a very very unsuccessful chess
in school some program and they have
really a ton a ton of very promising
junior players at some it's really
remarkable so you never know this might
be some world champ champion under 10 or
something and he got is titled this way
and he's very strong I don't know it's
just speculation maybe this guy's in no
time I in his 50s but I'm just stating
that it's it's it's always possible to
get some strong jr here from Turkey so
um okay he just sacrificed a pawn
interesting let's let's grab this I mean
bishops III was also possible but let's
go ahead here normally what needs to
react to this thread on this c3 with
Queen D 30 bishop d 2 107 but he just
allowed me to take
I'm not quite quite sure what to what to
make her this okay now I even allows
that I take the rook okay come on take
it so it's clear that he's got some
compensation so um the thing is I'm I
don't want to allow him to take on c5
and she went prevent castling I don't
want to take on the floor for example
this looks looks weird so let's just
just get out of this okay so um what I
want to do is of course be six but at
the moment the rook um would hang so
let's get out of out of this this
diagonal ah Queen a five maybe a queen a
firefly should have played but I can
still do that now and play b6 next move
good night somewhere hmm but 94 I can
play but should be seven okay so this is
good
I'm up what I'm just an exchange okay
yeah always should he should be sure
what is your material advantage simply
to figure out what how much material you
can return yeah this is actually here I
thought 95 would work yet this work why
shouldn't it and we can take with the
Queen though then we should a 6cm bishop
Kate I can take c4 and resins so he
needs to take on e5 Queen a3 this rug is
saying so this is not so great but
hmm I thought bishop effort to kabhi
forgot that it is still hanging
wait wait wait
hmm
yeah what the heck okay take care itm at
least it's a pawn I mean it was an
exchange now it's a pawn but at least at
some a very clean structure it takes we
can retake then it's really just a pawn
for fuzzyband nothing c4 is still weak
and if he moves to the Queen then I just
continue with a good yeah with a good
structure yeah but this rook it doesn't
go anywhere it cannot go to a 6 or
whatever this is really freely just
Justin nothing move it can go F 45 but
this is only five is a week porn I would
just win win materia now
'if I've takes takes a nice man hahaha
it's my move sometimes you're so busy
talking about all this that you don't
recognize it's your move it's look at
five now threatening can protect that so
on but I'm how do I actually make
progress now maybe I underestimated this
a bit it's not easy to to get to get
ahead here okay maybe switch over here
to see seven and play a mess maybe do
this play Bishop b7 some point
k jumana doesn't happen this is okay
should I play a five interesting yeah
probably other side is useful to do that
it really allows me to enter I just get
if I've now King f4f g5 maybe Bishop e7
now Bishop d7 takes and rook takes a
five this looks rather strong but it's
not so clear-cut amazing okay so then
let's switch to the Jeep on I had a sip
on
I completely overlooked it this isn't
hanging at all ah what the hell am I
doing here hmm no it's got this Jeep on
check
check
yeah I have no idea what's happening now
probably i'm losing and this was so
idiotic i simply overlooked so many
simple things in this and now I've
forgot to play rook g1 what the hell
time
check
at least it's a draw this is at least
something well I should be shot for this
game it was so completely winning I mean
after he imeem I'm not too sure about
that but after he let me in its just
resins basic in this position completely
completely winning I just forgot about
the simplest things here but man I mean
just just embarrassing really I can also
just take the April I mean everything
winds I think this must be what is
computer give Maya 25 points for black
yeah of course I mean it's it's just
dead but what the heck was i doing yeah
rookie rookie one yeah of course just
rupee one I can I I'm such an idiot
sometimes rookie one I just win e5
perform for nothing absolutely forgot
that that I'm not attacking and i
thought i would be attacking the bishop
but i'm not of course and this this gets
gets now very tricky it's got the g porn
and probably um yeah black needs to be a
precise 2-2 draw and i'm losing now it
was just very lucky that that I somehow
i'm going to draw out of this
yeah well no analysis of the last couple
of moves here this is really easy and
and I also of course bought it in the
opening I mean here yeah maybe it is it
is good for black and here I don't know
here here's an interesting he has an
interesting moment I just I just played
too quickly and have a look at this is
quite interesting and not this so got to
this point and here played f6 but this
move is much stronger look at this now
you five King seven and the issues if he
retreats the the rook I can just go
Bishop a six and win attacking c4 and
and it's it's gone and now I actually
managed to play f6 and he cannot we can
play this but it was not this here takes
takes f6 and now I managed to to take
and play and play this and wind upon
this is much better than what we had in
the game I had no way to attack a five
in the game this was the problem yeah I
hope you enjoyed the cake anyway it was
really bad at the end